yo when when pnb dropped out of the
fight I had heard you and Ray J were
gonna fight yeah
that almost happened right you never got
announced they never got announced and
[ __ ] but that was like a thing that was
about to happen right like he was in it
I would have been that would have been
that would have been funny that would
have been crazy yeah are you like done
with the fighting thing or can you I
think I'm done bro I ain't gonna lie
yeah because it's just like
it's just not like I feel like the
[ __ ] that's doing it actually really
want a box like they really want to
become and you're professional boxers
and I that's not where I'm trying to go
you know what I'm saying also you
probably have a lot more to lose of like
you get knocked out hell yeah yeah way
more to lose if I was to lose a fight
I'm done I already put my career on the
line once anyway I'm saying and that's
and I won so you know it turned me up
and [ __ ] so you know I'm the back's guy
I was thinking about it but it's just
like it gotta be
you gotta make dummy sense it has to be
the money has to make sense and it has
to be something that you're like I
there's no way I don't win this fight
yeah nah I mean I I want to fight
somebody that's like gonna give me a
challenge well this is what should
happen you and blueface drop the joint
album album release party is a
Pay-Per-View fight you guys fight each
other that would be lit see that makes
sense that makes sense that makes sense
you guys both come out on top because
you're out yeah so it's like he can beat
me up I could beat him up a little reach
you probably got the technique though
good you know that that'll make that'd
be something that makes Krishan Rock
she's like the referee
so it's your Fox because she's gonna you
know yeah
shoot my toy on you too yeah